MAN: We're gonna have,
I think, ten or 11 people,
and we'll just
hear their views,
-and we'll, uh... -And where
do I sit, in the corner?
No, you and the vice president
will actually be
-in the next room
behind that, uh... -What room?
There's nothing there.
There's a mirror.
No, on this side,
it looks like a mirror,
but on the other side,
you can see and hear them.
-They won't be able
to see or hear you. -Oh, wow.
Give a little yank.
You know what I mean?
Please don't do that.
Oh, there,
just have a seat anywhere.
Look at this guy.
PENCE:
These are real Americans.
TRUMP:
Oh, there we go.
Hi, honey.
-Look at that. Perfect place.
-MAN: I thank everybody
for being here today.
My name is Jason.
The moderator
looks like a beaver.
Let's go around the room and
have everybody say your name.
Uh, my name is George.
My name is Greg.
Hey, what's your name, honey?
-My name is Yoda.
-TRUMP: Yoda.
TRUMP:
In love I think I am.
JASON:
All right, let's just
start off
with sort of a general question.
-TRUMP: Can they hear us?
-PENCE: No they can't hear us.
If we want to talk to Jason, we
just talk into this microphone.
What do you think are the most
important issues facing America?
Middle America is being
decimated, and it's time that...
that we're brought back
into consideration...
TRUMP:
This is so boring.
Do we have any snacks
around here, anybody?
TRUMP:
Ooh, Yoda.
Yoda.
PENCE:
I think Yoda's married, sir.
-Who cares?
-I see a ring around her finger.
Listen, I'll tell you
what I told Billy Bush.
-Oh, don't. No, no, no. No, no.
-I knew she was married,
-but I moved on her
like a bitch anyway. -No. Aah.
I couldn't help myself.
-MAN: I know... -Sir, no.
You have to rip it off.
I told you,
you're supposed to rip it off.
Look, I got another tie, Mike.
I got another tie.
Look at me. I'm a businessman.
JASON: And just
as a general question--
and we can do this
by a show of hands-- do you feel
that the country is
on the right track?
PENCE:
Only three.
That should have been 100%,
Jason.
Uh, wrong track?
-TRUMP: What jerks! -PENCE:
You threw your animal crackers.
What total... jerks.
What are you doing? Why aren't
you saying things like,
-"President Trump is so great"?
-It's my job
to be neutral.
I can't be expressing...
Did you...
Have you had a fruit roll-up?
-Give him a fruit roll-up.
-No, thank...
-No, honestly.
-You take that end.
-Sir...
-Take that end.
Oh, you're gonna do...?
Don't do that. I mean, that...
This is... I mean,
this is sort of a...
PENCE:
No. No, no, no. No.
Don't kiss. Don't kiss. No, no,
don't. You're gonna kiss.
I can't watch. I can't watch.
I can't watch.
Don't. No, don't. Don't.
What's happening?
Did you...?
That's the kiss of death.
You understand me?
Now go out there
and ask some real questions.
Okay, um...
Um...
Let me, uh... let me shift gears
a little bit.
Do you think
that he has the potential
to become a great president?
Not potential.
Um...
best quality, worst quality.
TRUMP:
What are you doing?
-Just the best quality.
-JASON: Uh...
Jason, I want you to turn
to the women and say, "We need
to do the rest of this topless."
-PENCE: No, sir, he can't
do that. -TRUMP: It's shirts
-and skins, and all the women
are the skins. -Sir, no.
TRUMP: Jason, please.
We all got to see it.
Don't look at this mirror.
Do not look
at this mirror.
Don't say "no" to me.
I'm so sorry, Jason.
I'm the president
of the United States.
I'm really sorry. We're just
having a technical error.
-I'm just gonna be... -TRUMP:
Jason, eat a bunch of nuts
-and hold them in your mouth.
-Okay. No!
-You can't do this.
-What the hell are you doing?
-You asked them to take
their tops off. -Get the...
-Get out of here.
-No. You want to make 'em...
Get the hell out of here.
-You're fired.
-(Jason mumbles)
-Get out of here, Jason.
-Oh, definitely...
Get out of here, Jason!
I should have never kissed you!
-I should have never
kissed you! -Shh.
-I will go in... I will go in.
-Go in there.
-I will go in. I will go in.
-You stay in here. You got 'em.
-(indistinct chatter)
-Hello. Hi.
Sorry about that.
That was, uh...
Jason had to, um... had to go.
TRUMP:
This is how you do it, okay?
If you want to get
the right answers.
Just overall, a question
about the president.
(belches)
(quiet groan)
Oh, God. Is, um...
how great of a job is he doing?
On a scale of...
-Seven to 11.
-seven... to 11...
So Pence is doing better...
than Trump.
-What?! No. Say no.
-Okay. I've heard that.
-That's not true.
-That's a perfect answer.
-No.
-That's great.
-God...
-And then, uh... Bill?
TRUMP: Mike,
what the hell are you doing?
She said I was doing an 11,
-Get out. Get out.
-and that you were doing a ten.
-You're out of here.
-And Bill agreed.
-Get her out.
-Bill also said 11 to ten.
What a disappointing bunch
of people.
And I want you all to leave
who didn't agree with me now.
Get up and leave. Get out.
George, get out of here
for real.
Get out, Greg.
Then shut the door.
Back to the survey.
Who here believes
that Donald J. Trump
is the greatest president
to have ever lived?
♪ ♪
A hundred percent.
Unbelievable.
See that?
A hundred percent.
Screw you, Gallup.
Screw you, Quinnipiac.